minimalism is about so much more than
just decluttering and having an
organized home
it's a way of life
it's a mindset
it's the ability to find Value and
simplicity and savoring small moments
rather than chasing after the next shiny
object
or in this case the most prestigious
career hey guys I'm yesi and today I'm
going to share with you the perfect life
plan that sold to Millennials in
Generation Z I want to share with you my
view on pursuing a college education but
from a minimalist perspective I've
worked as an ICU nurse and a hospice
nurse for years and working with
patients in near-death situations and
currently an end-of-life care reminds me
all the more of the importance of
valuing our time I remember my high
school days and often hearing phrases
like life is short so enjoy it and the
ever popular YOLO
but it was often said by people trying
to excuse behaviors that they very well
knew were not going to lead them
anywhere positive in the long run
I've always been a very nerdy kid I
actually found my Biology book to be fun
to read and I loved algebra and
challenging myself I was definitely a
perfectionist and I did have a desire to
go to college but even then there was
always something that made me feel
uneasy about my high school days and it
is that it seemed like the entire point
of high school was to prepare us for
college from making sure that we had the
right grades the right extracurricular
activities and enough community service
to get into the right college to get
into the right job and it felt like my
entire life had to be decided at a point
when I didn't even know who I was or
what I wanted in life and an aptitude
test was to determine what part of the
assembly line I would work best for
don't get me wrong I am not saying that
you should not pursue a college
education I have a bachelor's degree in
nursing and I needed a degree in order
to become a nurse and I never doubted my
decision but I remember that when I was
a teenager in high school I kept
thinking to myself but how can it be
that everyone is expected to somehow fit
into this box and how is it that
everybody can figure this out
in what seems like a ticking Time Bomb
about to go off graduation day right I
couldn't help but think that this can't
be the perfect life plan for everyone I
mean surely a doctor has to go to
college but does everyone need to go to
college in order to find success and
meaning and value in life and even
though I was this nerdy straight A
student who had high expectations of
herself academically I asked myself this
question a lot because it seems like I
was going to school only to learn how to
be a good employee and not about how to
find fulfillment in life how to manage
my money and invest or how to completely
forget about working for the assembly
line and instead Be My Own Boss I
actually did take an entrepreneurship
class in high school but even then what
was taught was how to set up a physical
business or a franchise and it never
touched the subject of passive income
and its importance for financial
Independence and early retirement I
wasn't taught about assets and
liabilities or how to manage money I am
so glad that I became a nurse and I'm
incredibly thankful that I was able to
have a college education but I think
that sometimes the system fails I want
to share with you a little bit about the
man that I admire most in this world my
dad he grew up incredibly poor in a
family of nine children with an
alcoholic father that was only around
when it came time to collect the money
that his kids had worked for and yes I
said it right kids my dad worked on the
farm even before kindergarten and only
made it as far as Elementary School in
fact he wasn't even 10 when he quit
school because it had become way too
difficult to wake up at 4am to milk cows
do work walk to school without breakfast
not eat lunch at school because schools
in Mexico didn't provide the service and
his family was too poor to be able to
provide it for him and then be yelled
and hit by the teacher because he missed
an answer because he didn't have the
time to be able to study or do his
schoolwork when he arrived home
because when he arrived home he had more
work to do my dad says that he would
often go hungry without a meal
throughout the day and many times he
would have one meal per day
so he quit school before completing
Elementary School in order to help work
and provide for the family he was a
child who didn't have a childhood by
society's standards my dad shouldn't
have the education that should in theory
result in financial well-being but he
learned something else he learned how to
work like a beast and because he was
incredibly poor and never having owned a
single toy as a child he learned how to
be content with little he learned how to
work hard and save money he is currently
in his 50s he owns several properties
and he now works because he wants to not
because he has to
he is financially independent
with a school education up until 10
years old I think that sometimes where
schools go wrong is that they try to
pressure students to fit into this
specific mold to go for this path that's
already been laid out for them when the
reality is that yes we need workers to
run the assembly line and yes we need
people to manage it we need both
but there's an even bigger factor to
consider here
both the employee and the employer spend
money and ought to learn how to manage
it and even more importantly than that
is that both would be more content with
life if they could see that the objects
or titles that we obtain in life are not
what will truly make us happy our
passions in life change we may go from
wanting to be an opera singer to a cake
decorator to a nurse to a home renovator
or whatever else but I do know one thing
when I see my patients on their deathbed
I know that they are not regretting
those fancy shoes that they should have
purchased at this name brand store they
regret the wrongs that they did and the
risks that they did not take out of fear
looking at the necessity of having a
college education from a financial
minimalist perspective I would say that
no you don't need a college education in
order to be financially independent my
dad is a clear example of that but
there's an even bigger picture to
consider and I think that it stems from
being able to enjoy whatever course in
life you take and recognizing that your
life will have phases
our walk in life is not linear and
that's the beauty of it
I am not at all concerned about whether
or not my children decide to go to
college my focus is on showing them how
to give save spend and invest wisely but
even more importantly than that that
they find gratitude for whatever they
have in life
it's gratitude that allows us to find
joy and simplicity to this day I
remember when I was first brought to the
U.S and I had not eaten a full meal in
weeks because I shared a meal between my
mom myself and my brother you could
clearly see my ribs at that point in my
life and I remember that an officer had
given me a bologna sandwich just bread
just baloney no condiments no drink but
to me it was the most amazing food I had
ever tasted in my life the most amazing
sandwich I had ever tasted
I can I can almost palpate the taste in
my mouth and you guys it was not the
sandwich it was not this fancy bread and
it was not this amazing baloney
it was gratitude
I was so grateful
what if we could live with that kind of
gratitude every day
how would your life be different
could it change the way that you view
your present and what about your future
I dare you to consider that the perfect
life plan is simply one where you strive
to be the best version of you
every day
if you're like me and you want to learn
about how to better manage your finances
a book that I highly highly recommend is
Dave Ramsey's The Total Money Makeover
this book completely transformed the way
that I view and manage my finances and
it's actually how I got started with my
minimalist journey and a book that I'm
currently listening to Via audio is baby
step millionaires the resource that I
love for audiobooks is audible Audible
has an incredible selection of over a
hundred and eighty thousand titles and
audiobooks originals and podcasts to
choose from either through subscription
or by purchasing and I love this
resource because sadly as I mentioned
often schools don't teach these things
so when it comes to learning about
finances books have been of tremendous
value to me for your own free 30-day
trial of audible as well as a free
audiobook you can use my affiliate link
down in the description box below that
is audibletrial.com yesi dot live simply
you can cancel at any time but using
this link does help to support my
channel so thank you in advance I want
to thank you for sticking to the end of
this video and for hearing my
perspective on something that's very
near and dear to my heart but I also
want to hear your perspective so be sure
to share down in the comments below I
hope that it's given you something
positive to think about and if you like
this video please give it a thumbs up
and share it with a friend and don't
forget to subscribe so you won't miss
any of my videos on minimalism and
living life more fully with less until
next time bye for now